the international monetary fund has just
released its economic outlook for
south-saharan Africa and it's quite
depressing to read the title alone says
living on the edge in a nutshell that
means a doubling of inflation the
recovery is stolen one in eight people
in the region on the brink of starvation
while Rising costs and prices are
increasing social tensions
from all this let's bring in Catherine
patillo she's deputy director of the
African Department of the IMF and joins
us from Washington hello Catherine so
the report is titled living on the edge
that sounds very depressing how bad is
Africa's economic Outlook
the title indicates that right now uh
policymakers in the region are facing a
very very difficult uh environment and
this is after a number of previous
shocks so countries had faced the
pandemic and now the spillovers from the
war in Ukraine and now given very high
food fuel fertilizer prices that are
like a laser beam hitting some of the
poorest countries and the poorest people
given they have large shares of food in
their consumption baskets there's really
a cost of living crisis in in many
countries and this is in the face then
of a very difficult global environment
where Global interest rates are rising
Financial conditions are tightening
growth is declining across the world
particularly in the advanced economies
and so the this compounds the the
difficult environment and then you know
domestically countries are facing a
range of different shocks also you have
climate shocks
um drought in the Horn of Africa one of
the worst droughts in uh sometime and
this is uh compounding also the food
insecurity problems and this comes at a
time also with very high debt
vulnerabilities so countries uh space
then to deal with these problems has
been compressed okay that is why help is
needed I mean as you say the IMF says
Africa is a region in the world that is
in the most precarious position so what
possible help is there and what will
that mean for Africa
so countries need to help themselves by
navigating as best they can with with
strong policies but they need
International support also so the fund
the IMF has been supporting countries
with
programs then financial support
capacity support policy advice and the
International Community also needs to
support with humanitarian support
helping countries that are there in debt
difficulties
and and providing financial support
through this difficult time in your
outlook you say that there are quote
significant downside risks so things
could be even worse am I reading that
right
that is the message now that I'm sure
you're hearing coming out of these
annual meetings globally we are looking
at a very difficult situation this year
um but uh you know unfortunately things
could could get worse and you know as
the managing director has uh been saying
quite a bit we need to hope for the best
but prepare for the worst and so we are
looking at
um the you know countries to look at
their own vulnerabilities and to be
prepared that uh globally
um you could find
um you know additional shocks from
tighter Global Financial conditions from
further downturns Etc and okay those
have spillovers into our region that
countries need to prepare for okay let's
wrap it up with this do African
countries have any grounds for optimism
for example in the medium time hopefully
in a long time too
tremendous grounds for for optimism I am
incredibly optimistic for the region
think of the youth population and the
fact that within 15 years or so half of
the global entrance to the entrance to
the global labor force will be coming
from the region so this is a huge amount
of young people large Market who are
going to be you know dynamic and
entrepreneurial
um Innovative you think of the you know
the innovation in Mobile money that
happens in the in the continent you're
going to have you know large markets
then and the potential
um with the energy transition that I
mentioned and the the continent's
potential there for
um a really
positive and vibrant
um contribution of Africa to its own
people and to the to the global
community